hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 1 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet we have achieved maximum
catfish but I feel really bad for you if
you've been having sex dreams about
Melisandre but the interesting thing is
there's a lot of book stuff happening
here even though they've said that the
show is going off-book so I'll try to
explain as we go through each of these
beats so top 10 WTF number 10 really
awesome tracking shot of the ball very
ominous as we zoom in on Jon Snow's body
like yeah we know what's coming and now
we're really in the [ __ ] because one of
the few people who actually understood
it had a weapon to fight them is dead or
seemingly dead I think we can all agree
that he's coming back the real question
is is how and when like which episode so
just everybody see how long you can hold
your breath till he comes back it is not
over till they burn that body and that's
the whole idea here that's why Alliser
Thorne was trying to get them out of
there
surrender and we'll let you go they want
to burn the body and they really also
kind of want to get rid of anybody
that's still loyal to Jon Snow because
they could be a big problem in the
future
you get a pretty good read on the rest
of the Nights Watch like Alliser
Thorne's like yeah I totally engineered
his downfall
but listen this is why I did it and like
half the Nights Watch is like okay we
got you yeah he was gonna ruin us all so
it's about half and a half right now but
most of them stand with Alliser thorne
that's why sir Davos sent edy to get the
help of the wildlings we need to get
people who owe their lives to Jon Snow
he was talking about the wildlings
but he also number seven WTF is talking
about the red woman what can one red
woman do against 40 men oh my god you
have not seen what she can do with her
vagina just you wait so she takes her
glamor off and you find out that she's
like 200 years old which is kind of a
good thing kind of a bad thing I mean
it's good because it shows you that she
does have power there is magic at play
but the bad part is is that she's been
crying this whole episode like oh my oh
my god her beliefs have faltered she
needs something to renew her faith I
have a feeling that the return of Jon
Snow will be tied up in that like
something really big is gonna happen to
reignite so to speak her faith but the
way they cut the episode is just to make
you wonder what is going to happen next
like how am I supposed to feel about
this like the ominous music as she's
looking at herself with you know like
her true self don't think it's going to
happen but Melisandre has POV chapters
in dance with drag
and that's kind of what this was she
looks into the flames of that fireplace
I don't know how they're gonna address
that on the TV show they they might do
it they might not because it seems like
most of the big flashbacks that we know
are gonna happen liked our joy that's
gonna be brand related stuff so number
six WTF Jamie returns with Marcella we
get to see like the whole gamut of
Cersei emotion she goes from happy to
dead inside within the span of like two
minutes
that's like the whole spectrum of Cersei
emotion but how cool is that the Jaime
is like we're gonna take all this back
he almost sounds a little sinister like
we're gonna take everything everything
they took from us but then on top of
that he says we're gonna take everything
very ominous now you're thinking about
that trailer shot of him with the
Lannister army and Lannister armor and
it actually makes you think number five
WTF Roose and Ramsay talk about
everybody that wants to kill them which
is pretty much everyone in the north and
the crown although they mentioned the
Lannisters I had actually forgotten that
small detail about how he had married
Ramsay to Sansa in opposition to the
crown like Cersei was not down with that
so just like Tyrion says everyone wants
to murder you it's the same thing for
the Bolton's and I mean we know he's the
audience we probably want to murder them
too if you have a friend that's a really
big fan of Ramsay you probably should
not be friends with them anymore but my
number four WTF this is so funny such a
funny moment with Ramsay where you you
find out that he does have a heart but
it is a very blackened evil heart
Miranda she was the only one who wasn't
afraid of me what could I do to her that
those dogs wouldn't no no don't burn
that body that's a good meat feed it to
the dogs yeah it's shocking so you know
you kind of laughing you're like oh my
god did he just say that but the even
funnier thing is that he says that
completely annihilated still totally
good number three WTF Brienne saves
Sansa she finally accomplishes one of
her goals and he had this really
touching ceremony so what's happening
here when they were exchanging vows you
know she lays down her sword and gives
her oath to Sansa Sansa gives the Lords
oath back there's a reason that it
sounded really formal and they had this
really soft music behind it it's meant
to be like the beginning for Sansa like
the beginning of the rise for Sansa she
literally got drugged through the mud
and now how stark is starting to rally
so she's acting like the head of a
household would act when a knight enters
the service of a lord you will always
have a
placed by my heart so Sansa is the new
Lord Stark are you should say Lady Stark
because she's a woman but this is just
the beginning for her it's gonna be
really exciting she's gonna be one of my
favorite characters of this season in
addition to Brienne so whatever Brienne
does this season will probably be on the
orders of Sansa which is probably how
she ends up in Riverrun like we see in
the trailer we also have to give a
high-five to reek who seems like his
English has gotten a lot better like he
could barely string a couple words
together last season but now he's
speaking again so his TV show character
kind of headed in the same direction
that his book character said it just
slowly redeeming himself for all the
terrible things that he's done number
two WTF tyrion and varys try to fix
marine so they're walking through the
streets I love that this woman thinks
that tyrion wants to eat her baby
oh no no his high Valyrian is just
really shitty he just wants to give you
some money here you go you walk like a
rich person there gonna be a lot of
funny characters this season but most of
the time these two together provides
some of the best jokes in the show
couple really important things happen
during their conversation Varys says
that his little birds are looking for
the identity of the harpy so we'll
probably find out who it is this season
I had previously thought that it was
gonna be his door but it seems like he
died last season so it can't be him we
see more red priests trying to incite
people to riot when tyrion says this is
gonna be a problem
he's just sent you know like even the
priests are inciting people to riot the
harpies are inciting riots so everybody
is going to be fighting in the streets
soon if they don't find a solution in
the ships have now just burned so nobody
could go to Westeros even if they wanted
to which is where I'm hoping that you're
on Greyjoy comes in later this season
but remains to be seen
we haven't met that character yet so we
might meet in next week or an episode
three number one WTF now though and if
you guys head and guess there's like a
bunch of moment that I have to talk
about after this like bonus moments
there's no way I could fit this into a
top ten video so I'm gonna say like the
actual number one WTF moment is the
killing of all the door and characters
the Martel's that's the biggest
departure from the book that I've seen
thus far like there have been storylines
that they've just skipped over like they
skipped over Lady Stoneheart they
skipped over the young grift storyline
but this is like the most vast departure
from a big storyline now you know maybe
George or Martin was gonna do the books
maybe not but by by Dornish master plan
I hope you were not a big fan of that
theory so I don't know how big the sand
snakes are going to
be this season but it just it's horrible
to see what happened to areo Hotah
because remember that big moment he had
last season with Jamie where he's like
if you had been whole it would have been
a good fight areo Hotah is one of the
best fighters in A Song of Ice and Fire
so for him to go down like this I can
understand if you're screaming behind
your computer your TV or however you are
watching this like I can't believe they
just did that but goodbye dream Martell
goodbye trystane goodbye house Martell
just in general what I'm wondering
though is that ilaria sand has this line
where she says Dorne will never be ruled
by a weak man again I'm wondering if
this season in general is just gonna be
more female centric like you have Cersei
on the rise Sansa is on the rise
Daenerys seems kind of weak right now
but she'll obviously rally as soon as
drogon rides into town so maybe there's
some extra meaning in that line because
Tommen is kind of a weak ruler you know
no weak man will ever rule here again
maybe that's just like a generalization
for the entire series but let's talk
about Daenerys but you know bonus WTF
moment Daenerys is now bound by Dothraki
custom like she's a victim of that now
like oh no you gotta go hang out with
the Doge Colleen they are part of the
books
it's basically what happens when it cal
dies they kind of go into like a form of
mourning so the temple of the Doge
Colleen is just where they live their
days out
it's like Florida for former Dothraki
Queens so they're basically telling
Daenerys no there's no way you're going
back to marine you have to go live here
so that's who these people from the
trailer are the Doge Colleen but we know
Drogo shows up at a certain point so
once he does I think she'll be fine but
it seems like this character here who
used to serve Khal Drogo his name is Kal
Mauro so it's a slight change from the
books doesn't really care about Daenerys
although they do have that funny moment
where the guys like do the carpet match
the drapes
under if all of her hair is the same
color and then they have that argument
about what their favorite thing to do is
like laying with a beautiful woman
that's one of my favorite things no no
conquering other people that's the best
thing to do okay so yeah that's cool too
but also laying with beautiful women
that's cool so even though a lot of
people are totally screwed in all these
different story lines including Aria
that we'll talk about in a second there
are a lot of funny moments happening but
I should say in the books the person who
takes over who kind of like fills the
power vacuum whenever Khal Drogo dies is
Khal jhaqo
this person is Cal Moro on the TV shows
but he is a character from the books
just the person who absorbed most of
Khal Drogo's forces are you though arias
storyline pretty simple she's basically
daredevil now if you saw daredevil on
Netflix she's gonna have to learn to be
a badass while she's blind there was
also a nice callback where you know you
hear the people in the distance talking
about did you see what happened to that
Kingsguard so they're just addressing
some things that happened last season in
Braavos you see that Titan in the
background we haven't seen the Titan in
a while to tell you that Aria will
become a Titan eventually when she
learns how to live blind so I think
that's just for shadowing that aria also
another woman on the show is on the rise
so I think the subtext from the story
here is that the women on the show are
gonna be super badass this season but
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and do you also did you kind of pick up
on that the idea that most of the women
around the map even Daenerys who doesn't
seem like she's in a position of power
right now are going to be rallying big
time part of me thinks that that's why
they're holding off on bringing Jon Snow
back because if he came back then that
would kind of undercut the rise of all
these really powerful women like if Jon
Snow came back right away
then you wouldn't really be thinking
about the rise of Sansa they really want
you to see how she's coming into her own
she's going to learn to be the true head
of a household build an army reclaim
what is hers in Jon Snow coming back
would kind of derail that because you'd
be like okay well Jon Snow's got to lead
the army now he's got to take back
what's his because he's a stark
so just remains to be seen and bran is
coming back next week most of the
characters you didn't see in this
episode will be in next week's episode
so if you wondered where some really big
characters are you'll see them next week
but new round of the giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I do a weekly Game of Thrones
giveaway so what I'm gonna do next is
post a Q&A video I'm just gonna wait
till you guys have time to see the
episode and I'll just pull all the
biggest questions I have a feeling what
some of them are gonna be you know
mostly Melisandre Jon Snow related
what's gonna happen with Daenerys how
she's gonna win control of the Dothraki
what Tyrion is gonna do in Mereen who
the true identity of the harpy is I'm
really interested about that and when
Sansa is going to start building her
army because sir Davos has to get out of
that room first before he can start
helping Sansa build that army but
overall great episode you know it didn't
have as many you know crazy over-the-top
moments that I'm expecting in later
episodes think they did a good job of
seating some of
moments coming in the future in
surprisingly there weren't that many
storylines that went wildly off-book
like arias stuff is still relatively
book related John Snow is kind of right
at the end of his book story so is
Daenerys but the stuff in Dorne that was
like the wildly off book so when they
say wildly off book the Dorne storyline
is now off the rails different from the
books
so why you guys wait for me to post that
next video you can click here just for
like a general guide on like all the
other big story lines they'll be doing
this season I tried to do like a big
guide video for season six and you can
click here for all the other big trailer
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight